I know how you must be askin breaths
when is alone
hopeless you probably deserve it
thank you I started this video too early
of use there is still away thank you I'm
gonna bring it all back Oh
bringing it back bringing it back the
one who precious thing you ever truly
desired my that finish it okay cool oh I
love the picture dorian gray it's a
great story okay so welcome to layers of
fear we play this before and i wasn't
sure the game is out now obviously the
full game i wasn't sure if it was worth
picking up or not because i didn't know
but i read the reviews and it's amazing
and also I wasn't sure if I was gonna
play where we left off or not and it
turns out they changed a lot so it is
worth to start off with from the
beginning I think that's the general
idea I got and I think you bros want to
see what changes well so there are gonna
be parts that we own our own really
familiar with but there are gonna be new
parts as well and overall it's gonna be
a great game and it's been a while since
we did a horror on this channel so I'm
very excited to check this out and I'm
be really enjoying doing more series for
you bros because I feel like that's a
good thing and okay dear sir we would
like to ask you to cease bothering our
pest control specialists as well as
refrain from sending us any more of your
highly inappropriate letters of your
dick that was not there but I'll have
you know that my mother is a respectable
woman and
take kindly to your accusations all of
our employers that visited your house
reported absolutely no signs of rodent
infestation of any kind and as such
decide not to act further than a pro
whatever spraying please read this
letter as a final warning the next time
Lobby was a brave will be from our eyes
from Carl Denton Pest Control's all
right all right all right all right safe
oh god this game is so dark like I can
barely see anything I recommend you
watch this in full screen because Jesus
Christ I do not see [ __ ] oh yeah so
there's this note sir I didn't touch the
workshop just as you asked although I
can't imagine that mess that's inside
what set also if you care so much for
that room maybe you should pay attention
to where you leave the keys I brought
her back to the office that is the that
is the the note the the thing that I
miss first time I played is and I swear
I walked around the house for like an
hour
lovely painting potato man love potatoes
too
the game is so Atris Rangi it's been a
while Oh Jeff bloody [ __ ] my god
already [ __ ] forgot how many jump
scares this game have in our workspace
honestly I can't see anything I got up
at a little bit how am I supposed to
talk got [ __ ] me well nevermind I guess
I can't see anything to see that stool
that it's not like that what happened in
real slow Red Riding Hood oh how lovely
[ __ ] hell thanks for that I suppose
I'm sorry I'll make it up to you tonight
is all about you and me let's make it
special
you brought it that's what Jack told me
that's what Jack told me but no he did
not touch my balls
okay yeah no this is a lot nicer it says
I have a bright light in my face I need
to make it really [ __ ] hard to see
stuff also I think you bros have like
the white space on YouTube around you
and it's kind of the same effect look at
that there's paint on the stuff let's go
in
alright let's begin this adventure
really excited for this painting I was
gonna say there's I'm Nisha is this is a
closest term Nisha that I've seen lost
you deserve it finish it that I've seen
obviously a lot has changed since then
like I've become a lot more comfortable
with horror games we just think it's
something that I'm never gonna get back
but I really do appreciate horror games
in a different way now it really does
take a talent to do it well I would say
I think when we leave now the room is
gonna be different get it right this
time
they really should change that fun
because that's like a free font and I I
think it would be cooler if they just
wrote it by hand like I don't know that
took away a little bit of immersion
because everything else is so
high-quality in this game oh look the
game is different I'm sorry if it seems
like I'm not scared at all it's because
like I played this so far so it's a lot
like I'd be pretending it right coach a
play see I guess I don't remember and
now it's different
I'll get into it eventually
so what happens when you wet the couch I
love all the paintings
I love creepy art I used to go to Ebay
all the time just looking at like old
random artists that did like really
weird stuff cuz anyone can do creepy
stuff now but if it's old creepy stuff
then it's just [ __ ] up oh yeah here's
the code it's for eight sorry for 85 so
far there's not been many changes but I
know there will be and I'm glad you're
here with me if you want to jump ahead I
mean I the [ __ ] is wrong with you don't
jump ahead
I guess I'm yelling it's if you already
jump that and then thank you for being
here I appreciate you marry me that's a
pretty ring that's a very creepy way to
say will you marry me I'm gonna give
Marcie a ring don't tell Marty it's not
a wedding ring
okay so calm your pants but I realized I
never gave her one and I thought it
could be sweet don't tell might say that
I wanted it to be a surprise that was a
stupid idea why don't know why I'm trust
you bros to keep any [ __ ] secrets oh
god is that a baby in the painting oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god you flinched you don't
even look at me like that
oh me [ __ ] [ __ ] where am I where the
[ __ ] am i where the [ __ ] am i I can't
see [ __ ] oh here we go a barrel I knew
it I was right I was right those five
years ago and I'm still right again was
that like
oh hey it's just a guy and you look good
Hey look good are you doing oh my god
there's a lot of layers to the fares if
you know what I mean y'all know what I
mean so apparently the developers I
looked into them a little bit they made
one game that's like notoriously famous
for being bad so I think a lot of people
were critical when they came out with
this but I feel like this is their
comeback in essence because this game is
truly something special and like I said
it takes a special kind of talent to do
horror correct I think a lot of times it
can just be cheesy and that's a baby you
know and in a dolphin's no way the what
are they called elk in an elk
yeah whatever all right what do we got
in here do you see my eyes is doing like
this is I still struggle to see you what
the [ __ ] I'm doing nothing nothing ah
yeah maybe the book globe we why should
we am i doing something what does that
sound hey girl what's that sound
everybody like what going did something
move with a globe not that way
we're gonna go to Africa we got I go to
Spain I got I got a cool back we're
gonna go into my men brain okay good
dress good rhyme Pierce thank you for
that
that is a broken man hello
how's everyone doing creepy corridor see
faces Christ faint deep lice No Oh
fainting now oh yes just like that
hold that pose I want to get all my
lovely curves just right yeah goddamn
that's [ __ ] weird why hello there
hello there Arnold
Oh err fapping no it's the fire yeah
German oh I should've seen that coming
what happened okay that's totally failed
I think the book hit me or some [ __ ]
old school references do we go back now
yep
this scene is so weird oh god I hate
crying girls it's gonna be okay
don't worry about it don't worry don't
worry about it
hello it's about time for us to talk
don't you think I'd refuse to speak for
a brush we've seen you in my house so
many times and yet I could never find a
courage to face you directly not until
now let me double check that I am
actually recording yeah okay
I've done that a couple of times and
especially with horror games if you
losing a recording you're kind of [ __ ]
because you already played it there's a
lot of paprika I love paprika I love
that movie it's so good these bottles
are gonna smash my face feeling this
isn't you hello how's it going bros my
name is PewDiePie
ladies say he's a cutie pie millions I
had the disagree and say he's just a
stupid guy but whose that's right
perfect
The Dude's are right I don't know the
Rings oh god not this [ __ ] place the
[ __ ] kitchen oh my god carrots I love
carrots what is this this is different
hello I am having a lot of fun how's
everyone doing gonna cook some hot puree
lovely Oh what are not the Apple thing
again
that doesn't even make any sense what's
that hey ay ay ay
I could probably make an apple factory
macmail are they disappear oh God
goddamn oh just look fun [ __ ] I forgot
about it
god damn you know this spoon okay all
right we're fine big deal big deal
apples how about them apples
sorry some reflux was a nervous tic can
I go home now
okay thanks no I guess not
can still scales [ __ ] can still live my
life the way I want to live it oh yeah
there's a cyst I'd looked for a canvas
not just any canvas if not a penis I had
to find a knife not one of those brett
ones it needed to be as sharp as a razor
so i used a razor in fact and then
carefully flayed the skin booze helped
keep my hands steady
wait that is nonsense all right we
collected our first item so the way I
understand it yeah there we go
we could use that on to finish our
painting it's really cool really cool
concept and yeah and there's the
flamingos again good old flamingos hate
even now lost you deserve it finish it
fantastic all right let's keep heading
out we got more [ __ ] to do oh the
elevator
yeah this is really immersive and this
is really bringing me back to the old
school days I'm really enjoying sharing
this with you Bruce
yep I lick my moustache all right
usually I edit it out but now you get
footage of it that was a pretty lady
thing just gets a chi all right I know
why this is damn double microphone that
[ __ ] not sure how I feel about this but
uh all right let's here we go hello
hello every cool work we'll watch okay
hello it's very quiet I feel very nice
what was that
probably a fart oh [ __ ]
is it here yeah okay is it no okay well
I don't know that maybe I'll go in here
oh oh oh this is cozy Oh a kiss thank
you
is that a blinking murdering your woman
and that's a baby flying with the butts
out and the peepee
and that piano is playing music for me
why did you stop that dude was perfect
honey please just a little longer long
at least until I finish painting this
one part oh don't make me beg
he's so awkwardly sexual like I thought
I was awkwardly sexual but that's his
[ __ ] weird man
oh I don't make me beg
tell them I said that next time oh don't
make me beg imagine that's a good one
this game is giving me great dating
material it's awesome I love books
clothes latest fashion gotta stay on top
of that it sounds like intense fapping
but I think it's a fire I always get the
two mixed up know where oh oh god oh god
this is different I don't like this oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do I do
oh god I hate addicts they freak me the
[ __ ] out what the [ __ ] do I do
hi hi hi hi hi hi how is everyone doing
here this is great
don't let Oh careful careful careful
okay we're fine I don't know what I'm
doing up here oh there's a door I don't
how did I miss that
okay careful now gotta be careful oh god
oh god this is different oh god I don't
like this
Oh jab let it fit us
god damn what is going on I'm just gonna
go I'm sorry baby I didn't mean to spank
you probably cuz he legal left the baby
the eagle has the land I left the baby
I repeat someone kissing me no you can't
have this it's for Marty only sorry
Bruce
I know you want this I know that's why
you're here like he's so hot and I'm
like think I don't know that get out of
here I wish I could interact with
objects that was a thing with amnesia I
really really enjoy okay like I don't
see what the [ __ ] that is so I'm not a
gonna bother JA damn do they get you as
hard as they get me cuz Jesus Christ it
goes right up my [ __ ]
I flinch in a way you don't care okay
I'm sorry
too much info I I get it
god damn that's that's a painting of
nothing awesome my favorite painting
there's not what I don't have to judge
it like when kids ask me if I like their
paintings and I hate Oh God
okay okay I'm sorry I love your painting
I'm like it was great look it was great
now we spin the globe I know there was a
thing with it you spin my head right
round red
round when you go down be a bit there's
a mark there isn't it I see it there's a
piece of blood all right that's just a
Madagascar I always get them mixed up
that's embarrassing
oh yeah this is the dog thanks guy shut
the [ __ ] up they go shut the clock out
Oh God look what you did yeah piece of
[ __ ]
god damn it ed Gary you ruined my life
my [ __ ] life
god I I wish I think by Edgar so many
times like he just made my life so bad I
feel like crushing that waste but I
guess I can god there's so many doors
and [ __ ]
I suppose we just should stay on track I
feel like I'm limping a little bit am I
wrong
yeah I'll bet
what sorry wrong door okay Jeff loudly
oh whoa I got my eight mouse rats look
what you did
got Danny I was Edgar I swear to God FTC
that piece of [ __ ] he's out for me I
knew it stop stop [ __ ] with my house
Edgar don't look so bored
you too I'm kidding you look beautiful
okay uh yes there is a lot of changes I
am glad I replayed I mean sure we we
spend a little Oh God [ __ ] me
god [ __ ] damn it god [ __ ] dick
[ __ ] it a buck [ __ ] him like a phone
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] styler [ __ ] [ __ ] iPhone
oh god it's open now you [ __ ] oh god
[ __ ]
okay what the [ __ ] am I looking at Oh
awesome
I can't oh god I didn't mean to click it
down oh Jesus Christ
it never ends oh god it's the monster
okay alright there's no one here
I'm really freaked out by that monster I
really hope we don't have to interact is
he gone oh he left and left always after
shape this is weird painting monster
probably came out of our painting if it
did then that's bad news
why did they all melt like what did I do
and I'm not that hot oh god sorry well
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
sad my god what a mess how absolutely
amazing but those stairs with that leg
of mine I think you'll have to carry me
to the bedroom once we move in